un autre rassemblement statique devait
avoir lieu aujourd'hui place des
invalides à paris en hommage à aurélie à
une policière qui s'est suicidé en
septembre dernier
mais ce moment de commémoration a été
annulée par le préfet de police de paris
didier lallement à la place des
organisateurs ont tenu une conférence de
presse dans un appartement
six mois après la mort de la jeune femme
de 27 ans en poste à sartrouville
syndicats de police vigie et
l'association hors service déplore que
la hiérarchie ne soit jamais inquiété
lorsque des policiers mettre fin à leurs
jours
les organisations qui étaient présentes
aujourd'hui dérange évidemment c'est
pour ça qu'on veut être au bout nous
cacher on veut montrer que tout va bien
dans la police on veut que ce soit le
meilleur des mondes
et il ya quand même quelque chose
d'assez intéressant c'est que le
responsable des ressources humaines sur
l'île de france c'est le préfet de
police nationale morts qui étaient déjà
en poste au moment du décès d'aurélia
donc biladi rien à voir circuler alors
que légalement c'est lui le responsable
pour tout ce qui est gestion des
personnels en ile de france et nomme
hertha autour de la responsabilité
hiérarchique autour des suicides et des
que vous allez l'a pointée du doigt
vous êtes traité comme comme nous on a
été traités vous avez des dizaines de
manifestations qui sont autorisés autour
de nous et même une qui a été autorisé à
la place de la nôtre et nous
fonctionnaires de police
nous on n'aurait pas respecté les
consignes qu'ovide donc on voit bien qu
à chaque fois qu on pointe du doigt la
responsabilité hiérarchique
il ya un gros problème et un gros
blocage